paris ça n'a pas que vous devriez et
danser sous des avant gardistes
tout comme ça malik
et c'est coiffé sa machine sous le
projecteur à led tri qu'ils savent on
donne deux semaines
allons je ne sais pas si ça marche pas
du tout les deux virages ça me va
tableau lumière bleue rejeté du coin
gauche de la seine la robe est balancé
au dessus de la tête
vous avez été éblouissante
armand duponchel directement le cap nous
allons faire entrer cette maison à temps
là j'aime aussi à doha
dans ces affaires c'est petit
c'est juste parce qu'elles sont
impressionnés
croyez vraiment allant de 7,6 à doha
maintenant je me suis trompé je pense
quand même que j'ai trouvé personne pour
me faire plus de mal
tandis que l'on sait
daigneault